yo boulet cam show blue lakehead podcast
the little bro is here swiping in the
mirror yep yep yep what's up man fool
hey congratulations on this new song bro
and it's not even new it's like a year
old
yeah we hell yeah [ __ ] like it's like a
year and a half oh yeah i was talking to
ace about that [ __ ] the other day he's
like well the song is like a year and a
half old
i want me to show this was it the
addison ray chick who popped it off
oh no this is like out of nowhere on
tick tock so i think she did yeah she
pushed it for real like she was the main
push on that [ __ ] right now
so um after she did the video it just
blew up i had like a million videos
on tick tock like a million plus videos
with the song
and in the background so i feel like it
was just a big blessing like it was
crazy i didn't expected that
like i didn't expect that that song to
you was it was it was the song like an
afterthought it may have been out that
long it was kind of like
it was like i don't know where that's
what i'm saying i wasn't even thinking
nothing of like i've stopped
like it disappeared and all that like i
was like alright it's time to drop
something else
and it was like i didn't even have to
drop nothing else because it blew up
it blew up yeah yeah 21 hopped on that
[ __ ] i got the remix out
it blew it up even more yeah yeah i'm
just waiting on the plaque
the plaque is it's got to be gold by now
man what it's probably
they probably gonna surprise me in a
couple days and just bring me a plaque
or some [ __ ]
you already know he's right here you're
getting a plaque you already know [ __ ]
this
this is the little [ __ ] that we got
going on we wouldn't you gotta explain
that you already know you're gonna play